[Music]
on this sunday night parked on
parliament hill
gridlock in the nation's capital
bad behavior from convoy protesters they
were demanding meals harassing
staff and volunteers and the next move
for police
tension in ukraine there is i think
better chance if you're prepared how
citizens are bracing for a possible
russian invasion and the direct impact
on more than a million canadian families
battered by a blizzard
whose hardest hit by the bomb cyclone
and a battle for the ages
nadal versus medvedev in an epic final
match at the aussie open
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
the protest convoy is still parked on
parliament hill tonight although the
number of trucks and people has dropped
significantly from its peak yesterday
our chief political correspondent david
aiken has been on the hill all weekend
and reports on what the protest has
accomplished and what's next david well
chris on saturday more than 10 000
people here very noisy but by and large
peaceful today only a couple of thousand
but the tones changed a little more
testy a little more confrontational
[Music]
businesses near parliament hill
including the ontario provincial liquor
stores would not even open their doors
sunday after protesters the night before
verbally and physically assaulted staff
for trying to enforce the very public
health rules on mask wearing and vaccine
passports the protesters are here to
overturn
one group of protesters harassed staff
at a homeless shelter assaulted a
security guard and stole meals that had
been prepared for the homeless it's been
super challenging for the staff it's
very discouraging so yesterday was a
very very difficult today we're hoping
for better today
at the national war memorial a protester
was filmed dancing on the tomb of the
unknown soldier and then overnight
someone urinated on the memorial ottawa
police said no arrests have been made
all weekend but they are investigating
vandalism at the memorial and to police
property protest organizers did not
respond to global news requests for
interviews
freedom convoy
a faith service sunday morning featured
pastor henry hildebrandt who last year
was found in contempt of court himself
for violating public health rules
we are so proud of you
truckers
truckers you did it
and in texas donald trump saluted the
protesters we want those great canadian
truckers to know that we are with them
all the way they are they've really
shown something
and why not many of those on parliament
hill are trump's fans he's the best
we need him canada needs trouble so
what's next canada's vaccine mandate for
international trekkers is staying in
place and in any event washington has
imposed the very same rule as for the
other public health restrictions these
protesters oppose they are rules put in
place in provincial capitals not the
national capital in any event the house
of commons will open for business monday
morning as planned and though prime
minister justin trudeau and his family
were relocated this weekend as a
precautionary measure the pm remains in
the national capital region and will be
back to work virtually on monday
meanwhile ottawa police and convoy
organizers are negotiating the safe
evacuation of all these vehicles off
parliament hill but will they be gone by
monday almost certainly they will not
chris
all right david thank you that's david
aiken in ottawa now to the ukraine where
rhetoric is ramping up over a feared
russian invasion today canada's defense
minister arrived in the country as
ottawa withdrew all non-essential staff
from the embassy in kiev ukraine's
president doesn't believe an attack is
imminent at least that's what he's
saying publicly but as ross lord shows
us anita anand and other western allies
say intelligence shows the threat is
real
with an estimated 1.3 million ukrainian
canadians rallies like this one in
niagara falls are meant to raise
awareness of tensions in ukraine many
demonstrators fear for their relatives
in their homeland there's no happiness
there's no joy
because you have this ominous army on
the on the border nato is still sorting
out what to do about those 100 000
russian troops at the border making it
clear there are limits to its
involvement in the event of an invasion
we have no plans to deploy nato combat
troops to ukraine
nato allies have trainers there we help
them from nato with
building capacity modernizing their
defenses including their cyber defenses
the military response is not guaranteed
because ukraine is not a member of nato
the ukrainian national federation of
canada says signaling restraint makes
sense saying you know there's going to
be no nato
forces in ukraine
maybe a good thing to be saying today
but you know once the fern first russian
bomb lands or maybe when the first tank
comes in
you know that may be an opportunity to
change a position canada is not a
central player in world politics but the
government is making moves global
affairs canada confirming it's
temporarily pulling out non-essential
staff from the canadian embassy to
ukraine and defense minister anita anand
has arrived in kiev to meet with
canadian forces personnel deployed there
and with her ukrainian counterpart
ukrainian-canadian leaders are asking
all canadians to express support for the
cause through their members of
parliament
they're also raising money for a
humanitarian campaign in case it's
needed in the event of an invasion and
bloodshed
ross lord global news
across ukraine soldiers have been handed
their deployment notices and citizens
including thousands of women are joining
the call to arms our europe bureau chief
crystal gumansing is in kiev tonight
two sergeants both under 30 about to be
deployed to ukraine's conflict zone in
the eastern border region known as
donbass
canadian soldiers from operation unifier
helped train the rapid response brigade
members global news met up with the
soldiers at a military museum
raptor that's his call sign says this
will be his fourth deployment in the
region where the ukrainian military has
battled russian-backed separatist
factions since 2014.
he explains at first his parents and
brother worried about him but he says
now it's harder for his parents his
brother is being deployed with him in
the national guard
maverick again we've agreed to use their
call signs instead of their names says
he's ready this is his first deployment
he's trained but says he knows he can't
prepare for everything
far from any battle lines these women in
kiev are also bracing for a worst-case
scenario they aren't soldiers but they
want to know how to fend for themselves
and their families if civil unrest hits
close to home i was really scared i had
bad sleep at night and i was thinking
about that they need to develop plan a
plan b and plan c and we all know from
the history of the recent conflicts that
more civilians actually die than
combatants
so i think it's essential you know at
least to know some basics i remember the
situation in 2015 for instance i also
had an emergency back i had a newborn
and had an emergency back
and i was really scared but
now my husband is going to join tertiary
defense
and i'm go i'm going to to have this
training and i'm going to find more
information and to be more prepared the
workshop's leader alexander beletsky
says canadians helped develop the course
the key thing that people should
collaborate because it's much easier to
survive together in groups and to
survive as a family as a person the
sergeants praised the women for learning
skills to protect themselves and
possibly their country
if it comes to that
crystal gamansen global news
keeve
the u.n says almost 23 million people in
afghanistan don't have enough food and
the world needs to take immediate action
the afghan economy has collapsed since
the taliban took control last august the
group's strict islamic regime has not
been recognized by the international
community which makes it difficult for
groups to access the country that can
provide aid and as redmond shannon
reports the world doesn't seem to agree
on how to help
each one of these afghan people have
sold one of their kidneys for less than
two thousand dollars this is not new in
afghanistan but it's becoming more
common as millions face starvation some
families even sell one child just to
feed the others
manny beg in the freezing cold
before the taliban regained control of
afghanistan in august the country was
hugely reliant on aid after the last
western flight left new sanctions
blocked aid money from getting into
afghanistan and 10 billion u.s dollars
of government assets were frozen the
western sanctions
are
creating a liquidity crisis
this past week norway invited taliban
delegates to oslo to meet western
governments and aid groups a major
sticking point the rights of women and
girls
they have to understand that
we respect their traditions but they
need to understand that we also have
traditions we represent the civilization
where gender equality is fundamental
every country has their own culture and
based on their
laws based on the religious values such
engagements
is a sort of appeasement to a terrorist
group opposition groups in afghanistan
say any aid that is getting in is being
controlled by the taliban there has to
be a better oversight there has to be
better conditions
because what we're seeing is
discrimination one community is
receiving everything that's going in but
others are being deprived from it
norway's prime minister insisted the
meeting was not legitimizing the taliban
but the start of a search for a solution
and there is no way around this you know
we have to talk to them engage them and
present very clear expectations but time
is running out the un says more than 4
billion u.s dollars of aid is needed
this year alone it is asking countries
to authorize humanitarian exemptions to
allow aid to get through the scale is
absolutely
critical right now
we're calling this a race against time
we need to get to families in very
difficult
hard to reach areas in the search and in
the wait for a compromise as always it
is ordinary people who are suffering
redmond shannon global news london
hundreds of people took to the streets
of northern ireland today to mark the
50th anniversary of bloody sunday
alexandre nash deceased
relatives of the victims gathered for
the annual memorial service on this day
in 1972 british soldiers fired on
unarmed civil rights protesters in
londonderry 13 people were killed more
than a dozen others were injured one of
whom died months later it was one of the
deadliest days in the conflict known as
the troubles no one responsible for the
shootings has ever been convicted
just ahead blackouts and frozen homes
the bomb cyclone blizzard causing misery
on the east coast
many atlantic canadians are digging out
today after being hit by a powerful
nor'easter close to 20 centimeters of
snow fell in downtown halifax yesterday
but other parts of nova scotia were hit
with as much as 40 centimeters the heavy
snow and high winds caused hundreds of
power outages and poor driving
conditions across the province that same
storm system hit the u.s east coast it
has since moved on but dangerously cold
temperatures have moved in as jennifer
johnson reports u.s officials are
warning people who lose electricity and
heat to take precautions
the big dig out has begun
after the first blizzard of 2022 finally
moved out of the new england states
the bomb cyclone brought wind gusts
clocked at 134 kilometers per hour to
massachusetts coastal communities
waves crashed over sea walls and
battered homes streets officially
flooded
the national weather service reported
boston tied its record for the biggest
single day snowfall with 60 centimeters
76 centimeters in the nearby town of
sharon massachusetts
now tens of thousands of people were
left without power as temperatures fell
below zero this is where the
dangerousness sits in you cannot have
people in their homes without heat for
any length of time thousands of flights
have been canceled or delayed for a
second day new york's busy laguardia
airport looked like a ghost town sunday
the storm dumped snow in places that
rarely see the white stuff including
rehoboth delaware where u.s president
joe biden has his summer home and cape
charles virginia certainly for me this
is enough snow for the rest of my life
but the weekend storm was welcomed by
many some skiers enjoyed the quiet roads
others took part in a massive snowball
fight a couple from rhode island even
went ahead with their outdoor wedding i
now pronounce you husband and wife
adam you may kiss the bride not even a
blizzard gusty winds and bitter
temperatures could stop this happy event
jennifer johnson global news washington
an urgent appeal during the opioid
crisis harm reduction advocates fight to
stop a new and controversial id policy
in alberta next
you're watching global national
tomorrow alberta's top court is expected
to decide whether the province can
proceed with its plan to become the
first jurisdiction in canada to require
anyone using a supervised consumption
site to present a personal health care
number the alberta government says the
regulation is necessary to improve
community safety but as heather yorick's
west explains advocates fear it could
keep people away from the sites
ultimately costing more lives
on september 22nd 2021 airton hughes
became another casualty of alberta's
drug poisoning crisis he's just the
number he's just a statistic within this
problem but he wasn't he was a son he
was a brother a grandson a nephew the
crisis in alberta is escalating in 2016
there were 685 deaths in 2019 that had
grown to 800 but by 2020 overdose deaths
surged to more than 1300 with almost
1400 in 2021 and that's only with data
from the year's first 10 months 22 will
be worse than 21 if you don't change
what we do
we are on a really
terrible trajectory
substances are more tainted than ever
it's why advocates like moms stop the
harm had been fighting against an
alberta government plan to restrict
access to supervised consumption sites
effective january 31st anyone using
these sites will be asked to provide
their personal health care number i
really worry that that is going to
discourage a large number of people that
are currently going to the supervised
essential services
from accessing them in the future a
government spokesperson says despite the
new rule no user will be turned away for
services for refusing to comply
meanwhile the overdose crisis is also
prompting action from edmonton city
council we need to be exploring all the
options to to make our communities safe
including the safe supply of
pharmaceutical choices on monday council
will debate whether to pursue an
exemption to the federal controlled drug
and substances act a move that would
decriminalize minor drug possession it's
already been done by vancouver toronto
montreal and the province of bc but it's
not something alberta's police chiefs
support drug decriminalization triggers
an immediate need for structural and
societal changes in areas that do not
currently exist an alberta all party
committee is currently looking into the
issue of safe supply with
recommendations due by the end of april
moms like aya hughes just want the dying
to stop as this crisis continues almost
20 canadians die every day heather urex
west global news calgary